sometimes you all have parties and
you'll invite me and I'll come yeah I
feel that no I don't think you do
because I tell you
because
go ahead and I don't know if this is
what he generally does but he comes
for a very
small
portion of time but here's how you know
I'm comfortable
I came
touche I think the last time we both
went to your house I think you were only
there for 20 minutes exactly but at the
20th but what it's quality not quantity
but is it 20 minutes with joyous
okay but is that your move yeah because
he okay we go to Sia's house the singer
but we're there for like 30 minutes I
think it's because he feels as though if
he stays any longer he's gonna make a
grave mistake he cannot operate
my career's over at 30 yeah 20 minutes
above my career could end yeah like so I
keep at 20 minutes
that's your move you came to my wedding
for around 20 minutes that's not true
I'll tell you how I'll tell you how I
know I [__] took a photo of the
actual
whatever the when you guys get together
ceremony ceremony the hopa what's a hopa
it was what we got married under yeah
yeah you were in the whole pot and I'll
tell you why I know it's been there for
20 minutes because just getting there
with the angels and the trumpet players
and all the [__] that you had took it
was like a Lord of the Rings [__]
Adventure it was like it took four hours
to get up there and then when I when I
got there I remember dude I'm telling
you number one the best wedding I've
ever been to but thank you but I don't
think you've been to a wedding
before that oh since
[Laughter]
yeah yeah but I remember getting
emotional that was you did a speak
because I'd never seen you emotional
yeah you have one emotion I mean which
is I'm going that way that's the emotion
I'm going now I don't even know if
that's an emotion but I'm going that way
you know I mean and and so when I saw
you get vulnerable like that I it just
it's like when my Dad cried for the
first time I want to see my dad cry once
I got emotional because you think oh
that he is a human being
right so when you got emotional I got
emotional that was a really cool thing
to witness yeah I did get emotional
during the vows but what I what I was
referring to is afterwards at the party
yeah because I think you drove up and
it's not the seven hours six hours you
drove up what day off yeah and then you
you drove back yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that was that was
like unheard of like I never six hours
or six hours or 12 hours right and one
day but think about who I would do that
for I could count on a hand right now
who I'll do it if Judd Apatow I would
drive 10 hours I mean there's just a
there's a distance right but if it was
like um like yoursi
[Laughter]
we have a comic at the store yoursi and
maybe five minutes I drive for him
okay so sorry yeah yeah I get it I I get
it yeah I appreciate you came I just I
was flabbergasted when we were at the
party and I turned to Mike young and go
where's Bobby and he goes uh what he
left I go oh was he was he feeling
no he went back to Los Angeles
yeah
it was it was I appreciate you coming
yeah I just there's not it was a great
experience we haven't had a social
I think the last time we went out that
was really a significant time was
on Holly or Sunset Boulevard on the
corner it's a Chinese place uh uh
uh east of Fairfax west of La Brea you
took me there yeah yeah yeah you
remember it yeah what you remember the
place
in fact I don't even remember I was
eating there I just said yes just for
the [__] thing
I don't remember that okay yeah that was
the only time we actually hung out
that's not true
that's absolutely not true okay I mean
first of all going to your house is not
hanging out for your little parties
you literally said hey what's going on
yeah but we still lock eyes and we
communicate yeah but we didn't even we
had dinner together oh all right all
right okay yeah yeah I guess that yeah
we had a lunch remember the lunch thing
I showed up at what's the lunch thing so
I I Seinfeld had a lunch thing a benefit
his wife had a benefit
and I I was I remember you being there
and you came by the table Yeah I said hi
oh this is when you were you left
because you were upset that
um his wife kept calling you Robbie no
Billy I